[Music]
famous and loved centers around my
character Paige Townsend
coming up in this business I go to
audition for a big open casting call I
think um I throw up
bring Paige with me she books it in her
whole life changes can't believe I'm
saying this but did we just find our
August Nia is a very successful producer
in Hollywood you were all friends before
and you're still friends now okay
everybody let's put on a show her son
Reynard Evan is now a very big movie
star
does she need to sign a confidentiality
agreement took care of their last night
raynard has a reputation for being a
womanizer yeah he has an image of being
the good boy I'm sorry if I let you down
I'm fixing it we've had to work really
hard to get to this to this point so
we're gonna do whatever we have to do to
make it work we get to see the glamorous
side of Hollywood and the show is very
glamorous but then we get to see also
what goes on behind the scene
Jordan Wilder he came from a dark path
and rayner's mom helped him out yes so
much going on besides the movie how did
you make it why not
I play Alexis Glen she's very feisty
used to getting what she wants parts not
really yours until the cameras start
rolling this show is like a geometry
class there's so many love shapes going
on there's love triangles there's
squares tangi Turner wants to be triple
threat she's got some drama
Godfrey you've never even cared about me
or what I needed what did you need tangi
Jordan there's great romance great
friendship epic drama lots of twists
turn surprises I can do the movie and
stay in school being a movie star isn't
a part-time job Paige some ways that's
entourage for women it's
it's time for the ladies to see some
action in Hollywood
[Music]
you